Yeah. I only went a month. Yeah.
I don't want somebody to, uh, the hide some manager for,
uh, for logged-in home. That how you
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] or back and forth. Uh
[inaudible] [inaudible].
I didn't know [inaudible] other than that.
Yeah. Everything
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] I can say it.
[Inaudible] yeah. [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
So Holly [inaudible].
Oh yeah.
[inaudible] the same money to Nathan.
[Inaudible].
Did they come [inaudible].
I was in front of her video. Say not, uh, into football.
They also get, uh,
[inaudible] Marta dog.
[inaudible] [inaudible].
They're not gonna stop on out. And the other thing I think, uh
[inaudible] gotcha.
Yeah.
[Inaudible] [inaudible] or since, uh
[inaudible] I definitely [inaudible].
Nah. [inaudible] or
[inaudible] so the [inaudible] theater up there. Oh, awesome.
So you'll have the fact.
That you can only
[inaudible] [inaudible] is that [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] Oh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] Debra or hold on name.
No.
Uh, we entered the hospital alone. The orienting, the
[inaudible], the [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Uh, [inaudible] nada.
[inaudible] I'll send you can [inaudible] [inaudible].
Good example.
[Inaudible] books. So men, uh, I think, yeah, mostly on my books. I'm familiar.
Nope.
No.
[Inaudible].
So
[inaudible] coached for me.
Oh, see, I think the [inaudible] so the
stopping the Jennifer.
Also pick out some hard
[inaudible] The ice man. Oh, y'all do
you have
[inaudible].
Yeah.
[Inaudible].
Give her, man. See, I don't tattoo most of all that from.
So yeah. That's what they did. They mix CATIA. [inaudible] some
[inaudible] to get done with
[inaudible] [inaudible] so that's what their mix of uh [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
Oh, headset. Well, that's for
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] that's what?
[Inaudible] IO
[inaudible] uh, or do I are to tell Manchester?
Um, or that are your
[inaudible]?
Nah.
[inaudible] um, so, um,
[inaudible] or how many open
[inaudible] [inaudible] bottom or maybe so.
[Inaudible] for them through not hurting for a long time.
[Inaudible] so you have to look there.
Ah, man.
[inaudible] Oh yeah.
[Inaudible] at home. Spill it in Manchester. United.
[Inaudible] man.
Then they have chicken [inaudible] if
[inaudible] was coming up on my hand. So
[inaudible] me, man, that knew I laughed at him.
Uh, the [inaudible] you have
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] Mon [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] Oh, [inaudible].
It talks to the AF [inaudible]. So it's for
[inaudible] Keenan [inaudible] football
team.
[Inaudible] do I, uh, do hopelessly
[inaudible]? Uh
[inaudible].
Yeah.
[inaudible] [inaudible] yeah.
[Inaudible].
Yeah. I only know.
Yeah.
Uh, Vic hide some monitor for, uh, for logged-in
how, uh, how you, uh,
the other component.
[Inaudible] inquiry or a back and forth, uh, log, uh,
throughput then footprints Bahamas fellow
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] I'll tell them that.
Yeah. Everything
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] I can say it.
[Inaudible].
Yeah. [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
We don't land dog. [inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] football.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] Chuck and then Harvey
The only [inaudible].
Oops. Cathaway Devassy.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] yeah. [inaudible].
Click on the year.
[Inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
The books for, uh, that you tie [inaudible] uh
[inaudible] uh, Monday bland. Never [inaudible] after much.
[inaudible] yeah. [inaudible] yeah, so [inaudible].
[Inaudible] Oh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] yeah.
[inaudible] [inaudible] Oh, there was a fair [inaudible].
No, David PlayStation
[inaudible] PlayStation spiel for YouTube
[inaudible] song called the end.
[inaudible].
It's like this [inaudible] American all over there.
Yeah, just Columbine
or dark [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] yeah.
[Inaudible].
The purpose of also the nurse. Yeah. We are more on threats. Uh
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
uh, throw it on the [inaudible].
Nah, want to the first time the boy caught another one.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] or the
[inaudible] let's do
[inaudible] we've to come in the door. So just
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
When, uh
[inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] what else to throw them in there? I can't think of [inaudible].
Oh, good. Yeah. They're harder. Excuse me.
[Inaudible] hope you enjoyed the clamp for more interesting conversations,
please hit subscribe.